[Music]
and the future is now news oh yeah oh
it's this time-travel
unlike time travel let me go submitted
by Minority Report oh yes
Bluetooth you know what else is Minority
Report when I get the police brutality
and I call somebody software claims it
can catch shoplifters before they steal
that's your D report yeah just based off
like behavioral patterns look what if
what if what could they [ __ ] with one of
the cogs yes haven't watched minority oh
my god it's been years I've got a while
dude it was in like 1998 called start
the prayer the the girls I can the water
right yeah and then they alter their
that's what they called it good as
memory dude I really like that movie
alright so let me show you guys the
video clip this is a Chinese company
that create a sari Japanese tech company
that created this artificial
intelligence not the same - that's why I
corrected myself I know but you said
that's a racist yeah correct I can't
believe he's a duck on that Indian oh
there's different types of Asians I feel
like this is plausible just because like
if they if they have if like when people
walk into a store and they have a bag
and they detect the bag and the person's
face and then when the person goes in
like if an item if like you can track an
item going into that thing that already
exists dude let me show you guys a video
clip oh this is in Japan Japanese tech
company developed trying to catch
Chinese dealers they're profiling that
black lady oh my god it says the action
they're looking they're picking up an
item
she's white I think you're saying
estimation could be stupid you don't
need a [ __ ] technology to see a bad
guy who's suspicious is fun that's dull
you might as well just put a guy in a
train track villian suit yeah we already
know you've the bad guy yeah well yeah I
guess this is so shop workers don't have
to like you know the cross on ourselves
and profile but they're also saying like
you know this would help shop workers or
like shop owners so they don't have to
fully focus on every individual that
comes into their shop because this this
AI is already doing it for them and
they'll alert the person the shop owner
and tell them like hey you know this
person is stealing right now in this
moment like there's a 96% chance that
they're suspicious or whatever because
they actually saw them track the item
and put it into their Oh touching people
waiting for them to steal is so [ __ ]
exhausting dude having to do that [ __ ]
at my parents door was so [ __ ]
annoying dude you have to look at them
and it's like it's just when you give
somebody the opportunity to steal
something especially in like a poor area
everybody's gonna steal like it's not
really a race thing it's like a money
thing like you're broke you know and
people just want to have stuff that they
can't have right now and it was so
exhausting - and I mentioned the story
before where my dad said well I used to
think that he was just you know being a
little racist [ __ ] and my dad's like
well you run the store then you run the
store let me see whatever happens dude
we had so much [ __ ] stolen you guys ever
think about like just putting that thing
under every product and then if they
walk up now you have to get the things
installed and their mom and pop yeah do
this should I borrow that's way to
expand it was just like when I was like
the biggest lesson that I had and my dad
was like it's not that I'm like
profiling people or anything he's just
like Pat smarty you thought he was
profiling when there's only one race you
exactly bias is that sounds kind of dumb
and my dad was like they're just giving
people an opportunity to steal stuff so
it doesn't matter who they are so I was
like oh [ __ ] and the hellish it got
stolen and that was my bad and I was
like I didn't really think about that
[ __ ] so I think that people would just
naturally steal [ __ ] when they just
can't I mean that's even true for
employees right yeah and accounting
always has like a certain sense of
set aside because they know that theft
is just gonna happen no matter what
hey staring at people but it deters them
if you look at him ya know I go [ __ ] I
don't know I'm just gonna say it this
looks like a Kickstarter advertisement
and it doesn't work it's too good to be
true I bet it looks nothing like that -
yeah exactly it's like real janky it's
super janky what if they go like facial
recognition and they're like Mexican
eighty percent eighty percent likely to
steal I mean if it was like it's like
hella racial profiling actual
identification that was able to like
pull up like your record or something
and it was like oh you've been arrested
for stealing before like at an already
part report where you have to like scan
your eyeballs or something isn't that
for the retinal scanners yes yeah yeah
they scan it because your ID that's
basically your thumbprint is in their
eyes at that point they could pull up
your records yeah and I heard is like
really [ __ ] good at this
Vegas because so there's this thing
called the black book in Vegas right and
it's a it's a band from casinos list
from sheets car counters people that are
yeah they've been banned from casinos
and then they all share it all the
casinos share it so then when someone
comes in that's a part of that black
book and they sit down and I want to
start gambling sometimes they'll get to
the table but a lot of the times they'll
get intercepted immediately as they walk
in because they have facial recognition
and and it's like that guy's here and
then the security alerts the people on
the floor and they'll be like go stop
them right now yeah casinos are little
countries dude I feel like casinos and
casinos might be even more better than
airports because casinos are like banks
and fortresses yeah yeah souls that
castles yeah and airports at the same
time my dad is to work out Commerce
Casino he's retired now but he seemed
like dealers that have like embezzled or
whatever and then the security just
caught it's almost like their own police
force - guys come just pick them up and
their feet are just dangling in the air
and they purposely embarrass them and
drag them out and then when they're
under the house Security's custody he's
seen people I get the ass beat and all
that and then they they have the
special jurisdiction up until the police
come and they're almost more grateful
that the police came because now there's
actual laws in place are you serious I
smell a mafia hell yeah they're
gangsters [ __ ] yeah they don't want to
[ __ ] with their money I feel like they
protect the casinos when in the city
because I lived in Vegas for almost a
year and I don't recall seeing a police
car really don't and like when you think
about it I feel like there should be
hundreds of police cars probably
patrolling the interstate looking for
drunk drivers because God knows they're
out there and like you know also I used
to I used to live with a girl that would
drink a lot and like she would drive she
would sometimes pick me up from work and
so like that she would be wasted I mean
this girl was driving drunk five days a
week literally that's another reason but
in her car yeah eventually my car broke
down and I was always riding with her
but I was 21 I was like hey whatever who
cares you know but like you always had a
furball caller thinking all the time I'm
like I cannot believe she drives drunk
every single day and doesn't get caught
but it's Vegas baby well and eventually
she did but it wasn't until she had a
car and so I'm like y'all need to be out
on the road looking for these people
every day because they they're they're
driving I didn't know that in Macau they
threatened you're not allowed to drink
in the casinos or something oh really
do you know I never been can't drink and
Gamble really but isn't alcohol gambling
in make sure they want you to gamble
responsibly that's so nice I was like
gang ran too yeah
so it's like different rules that they
want you to do it responsibly or some
[ __ ] I could be wrong but then Abe he
went to Macau recently oh so he said
like you don't want to gamble like a
madman Vegas used to be Gang grin but
not anymore its corporate ran that's
another kind of game you know yeah at
Vegas when you are if you if you win big
they'll be like how about a drink to
celebrate they'll get you yeah when you
win big they're like would you like to
stay at one of our awesome Suites and
then they butter you up and then then
you [ __ ] burn it off yeah that's how
they do
are you staying and you are you staying
at our casino and then you'll be like
actually no I'm staying at the motel 6 I
don't there's no way a big winner like
you you need to stay at one of our
complimentary Suites look it's on the
house and it's like you know you won
like 30 grand or whatever
and they're like I'll give you a hose
you get this VIP treatment and it like
come up I can't play games cuz you know
the longer you stay I'll do that [ __ ]
I'll do it too but I'm too cheap or
people will people will let the cocktail
waitresses know if you're a big winner
and like they want tips so they'll keep
coming to you yeah and they want to give
you drinks or they want your money or
you know like if you're gambling and you
just made like $5,000 and a hot girl
walks up to you and asks you if you want
a $15.00 drink you're probably gonna say
yes then you can get drunk it is all
over from there you got a good system
uh-huh they have a med David so how much
is that drink $15 [ __ ] no get the [ __ ]
out of my face you know that's just a
start [ __ ] I know better I know nice
try you think I packed my own lunch
exactly I got a [ __ ] sack lunch and
everything sauce myself thank you get
the [ __ ] off me man I got this oh you
know massage and gambits ain't that what
I like about Vegas is they try to suck
you everywhere they have people that try
to suck your dick suck your monies and
then even the weather try to suck you
dry so dehydrated they just try to suck
you [ __ ] just suck the [ __ ] out of
you and you like you know what though
we're talking mad [ __ ] but like this is
making me wanted to go to Vegas like for
a week like I do kind of this is awesome
anyway yeah we're talking about this oh
yeah oh yeah the [ __ ] racist AI I
would love that [ __ ] to be racist you'll
be so [ __ ] funny like you see like
they just go gonna compliment you in
your face but give you bad yelp review
you know I can probably see when they're
programming these AIS in the future like
they're setting out they're making all
the settings and they're like racism
zero and they're like just give it just
get them alone a little bit of bias
little oh yeah I wonder what they do
like candy do they have like a heat
sensor and then they know that like this
person's like bout to steal so they're
nervous and in there shaking body
don't be crazy some people like how much
are you sweating yeah then they do track
the item like the pickup I think that's
what the most is it's like the items on
their clothes they're saying that in
Japan they're gonna be installing it to
100,000 stores across Japan in the next
three years
oh that's so soon this time so easy to
shoplift in Japan
say though how expensive is that and
does it actually make up for the deficit
of theft over time that it has reduced
in those stores that they have
implemented it the shoplifting cases
were reduced by 75% damn oh [ __ ] that's
huge even like having a little
surveillance camera even if it's not
recording that deters a lot we just have
a camera that just it's just loud as
[ __ ] and it follows you so if you're
doing anything should be tidied
[Music]